Ось так роблять бетонну дорогу поблизу німецького Ерфурта.
Процес складний, мороки багато, але воно того варте, кажуть дорожники.
Така траса служитиме в рази довше, ніж асфальтова.
У Німеччині третина всіх автобанів - з бетону.
Першу таку дорогу побудували ще на початку
30-х років минулого століття між Кельном і Бонном.
Якщо асфальт у середньому служить років 10, то бетон - до 30.
А якщо вдало поклали і правильно експлуатують, то навіть ще довше.
У ФРН досі є ділянки з оригінальним бетонним покриттям ще довоєнних часів.
Окрім довговічності, експерти відзначають ще й безпечність та екологічність.
На таких дорогах не утворюється так звана колія,
тоді як на асфальтових влітку покриття нагрівається і деформується під вантажІвками.
Бетон - негорючий матеріал, і він не виділяє токсичні гази при нагріванні.
У європейських тунелях, приміром, покриття за приписами будівництва
має бути виключно цементобетонним.
Крім того, на таких трасах витрачається менше палива, адже краще зчеплення з гумою.
Гальмівний шлях у автомобіля теж коротший.
Бетонні дороги екологічно безпечніші.
Там немає нафтопродуктів, фактично лише цемент і пісок.
Плюс бетон підпадає під повну вторинну переробку.
Попри значні переваги бетонних доріг у світі набагато більше - асфальтових.
Головна проблема бетонного покриття -
треба дуже ретельно дотримуватися технології будівництва.
Якщо неправильно зробити бетонний розчин, він може розшаруватися,
і великі мінерали після укладання опустяться вниз, а дрібні залишаться зверху.
Це призведе до швидкого зносу покриття - верхній пласт фактично розкришиться.
"Ямковий" ремонт, як з асфальтом, у цьому випадку неможливий -
потрібно "перезаливати" цілу ділянку.
Особливої уваги потребують шви, адже внаслідок температурних змін
цементове покриття розширюється або звужується і може просто луснути.
Тому роблять ось такі прорізи на глибину 5-7 сантиметрів
і заливають їх герметиком.
У містах бетонні дороги
використовують вкрай рідко,
адже тут потрібен доступ до підземних комунікацій і мереж,
а з бетоном це проблематично.
Ще один мінус - прокладання бетонних доріг вимагає значно більше часу.
Бетону потрібно набирати міцність декілька днів,
а асфальт можна використовувати вже через 8 годин
після того, як по ньому проїхався каток.
Також побутує думка, що їзда по бетонних дорогах створює більше шуму.
Раніше це справді було проблемою, але сучасні цементобетонні покриття
за рівнем шуму фактично не відрізняються від асфальтових.
Будівництво цементобетонної дороги,
як правило, дорожче на 30%.
Але якщо враховувати, що така дорога буде експлуатуватися
втричі довше без затратних ремонтів,
то в підсумку цементобетон виходить дешевшим від асфальту на 30-40%.
Ціна залежить передусім від ширини дороги та рельєфу місцевості.
Три смуги плюс узбіччя у Німеччині
може коштувати 2 мільйони євро і більше за один кілометр.
В Україні ж, за даними "Укравтодору", цементобетонних доріг - лише 1%.
У найближчі 5 років хочуть побудувати майже 3 тисячі кілометрів таких доріг -
тоді в Україні частка бетонних автошляхів зросте до 3%.
Вартість одного кілометра бетонної дороги в Україні
приблизно 20 мільйонів гривень,
асфальтові - в середньому на чверть дешевші.
Але, враховуючи, що бітум
Україна на 60% імпортує,
а цемент - вітчизняний, різницю в ціні можна ще більше скоротити.
За словами експертів, необхідно нарешті змінити багаторічну практику в Україні,
коли дороги будуються так, що потім потребують постійного ремонту.
Це призводить до зайвих витрат або навіть розкрадання державних коштів.